hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial and this one will be an
overview of youtube insight 2.0 and i'll
go ahead and post this as a video
response to my original youtube insight
video
because this in fact has changed
actually in the past few hours uh
youtube had tweeted about it uh but
anyway you guys can now view a myriad of
statistics for an individual video as
long as uh you allow that so we're gonna
go ahead and search my uploads for
safari 4
and
i'm going to go ahead and go to my
safari 4 video video which has a large
number of views and open that in a new
tab and what we're going to do
is view the statistics for this video
now normally when you would go under to
statistics and data right here it would
show you know a small amount of uh
statistics it'll give you what sites
were linking to it how many uh comments
favorites you got etc let's go ahead and
hit statistics and data now and we
scroll down and we'll see this huge
amount of data
very very nice so you'll see first of
all the honors of this video then if we
scroll up because honors you know
they've been there for a while you will
see a whole lot of stuff now you can
share these statistics with the video uh
as long as you want or you could make
these private if you don't want everyone
to see this i'm gonna let this uh let
all my videos have all these uh you know
open so this is this is really cool
first of all you have a graph up here of
the total video views and this is uh
something google has thrown in where
each one of these little letters here
corresponds to a date and an event which
is really cool
so um
right here you can see there are 274
comments and has a graph of how the
comments have been increasing uh it
shows how the favorites have gone up how
the ratings have slowly uh climbed the
number of ratings and the average rating
has stayed at about 4.4
now if you go down here this is what i
think is the coolest thing it shows the
number of views you get from certain
things from from certain events that are
happening on youtube
so this is right here first embedded on
this website got 1182 views from being
embedded there uh some people google
search safari four four thousand four
hundred people clicked on my video from
google searching safari for
first referral from youtube and browsing
one thousand embedded at
video.google.com uh referral from uh
these three google google and youtube
searches so people search these
different terms and were actually able
to find my video
by searching these terms and people
searching safari 4
got a large number of views on this
video and other slash viral which is
just you know other ways people found
your video so i think this is this is
really awesome that uh by the way uh
that last
sorry about that noise in the background
that last event that happened got me a
large number of views so i really like
this this tutorial and this insight
right here
it really is a deep insight in your
video statistics now you can go down
here and see that your video is most
popular with ages and genders so males
ages 13 to 17 most popular and then 45
to 54 and 35 to 44 and you can also see
its most popular in these countries so
you can definitely go go to a
ridiculously viewed video
such as i don't know susan boyle susan
boyle's video was is pretty much
everywhere look at that 71 million views
and you can go down and as long as the
user has not disabled it if we go ahead
to statistics and data
no they have disabled it but if you go
down to the statistics and data of
someone's video you'll be able to see
all of that
now if we go ahead and want to delete if
we want to uh hide this and we don't
want anyone to see it go ahead and hit
that account button on the top right
hand side go to sharing and privacy
and go to statistics and data down here
and just uncheck make statistics and
data for my videos publicly visible by
default and save changes
you can also uncheck that for individual
videos if you don't like the statistics
that are being shown on individual
videos anyway thanks for watching guys i
hope you enjoyed this youtube 2.0 tour
sorry about that background noise and
please rate this video five stars get it
uh get it spread around and go ahead and
check out the youtube insight on this
video for yourself uh if it you know if
it's exciting enough for you anyway
thank you for watching and please
subscribe if you haven't already and
i'll see in the next video peace